[Musique]
ce mercredi 9 mai après la commission
permanente décentralisée qui s'est tenue
sous la présidence de serre et melchior
à bras panon s'est déroulée la remise
des prix du concours départemental
d'élevage un concours mis en place pour
valoriser le travail des éleveurs et la
qualité des produits
je le mets là à organiser cet événement
ça va se jouer là bas
tout le monde veut venir ici la réunion
donc j'espère que ça restera toujours
comme ça et s'en remet en avant les
éleveurs d agriculture donc
c'est une très bonne chose pour nous et
ce sont les catégories sont concernées
et très chef d'exploitation ont ainsi
été honorés
le président melchior accompagné des
élus de la collectivité de la sous
préfète de saint benoît du président de
la chambre d'agriculture a rappelé
l'engagement de la collectivité en
faveur de l'agriculture 80 s est pris à
ces familles d'agriculteurs ces femmes
et ces hommes c'est toute l'agriculture
réunionnaise qu'on va récompenser et
honoré et donc quelques personnes ont
été dans chaque filière
ce soit au niveau des filières élevage
comme d autres filières nous avons voulu
remettre ces puits doivent montrer qu'à
la réunion il ya travail de qualité qui
est fait par le monde agricole et
seppois cela que le département de la
réunion se trouve aujourd'hui encore aux
côtés des arts et culture de la réunion
[Musique]